[Music]
you heard it I laid it out in the two
angles the one thing Democrats made
clear in the second round of debates is
that there is a clear divide between the
radicals and Joe Biden here now to break
down the words and phrases that mattered
is pollster Frank Luntz okay Frank I
want to start with Biden now he's been
called the moderate one up there
but there was one radical suggestion
watch I have the only plan that limits
the ability of insurance companies to
charge unreasonable prices
flat out number one number two we should
put some of these insurance executives
who totally opposed my plan in jail for
those nine billion opioids they sell out
there Frank what about that so first off
did you hear the audience reaction to it
and I was there in the hall for both
debates and I want to make it clear to
the viewers that this is not a fight for
the soul of the Democratic Party that
fight is over and the hostility of these
Democratic candidates most of them to
corporate America to CEOs to those
who've been successful is significant
the language that I heard in the last 48
hours is language I've never heard from
any mainstream Democrat and every time
you went anti corporate anti CEO anti
success the audience just lit up with
applause now I want to move on to night
one and something said by Bernie Sanders
and Warren that's struck you let's watch
[Applause]
is corruption it is giant corporations
that have taken our government and that
are holding it by the throat and we need
to have the courage to fight back
against that anybody here thinks that
corporate America gives one damn about
the average American worker you're
mistaken stand up and take on the greed
a corruption of the ruling class of this
country Frank isn't that what Obama said
he was gonna do I mean standing up for
the little guy so can a Trump is already
done this is so much more extreme
holding the government by the throat
it's graphic it's visual and I
every CEO who's watching right now and
every corporate executive they're after
you they're blaming you they're holding
you accountable I attended the SEIU
rally because I wanted to see what
language they used and what they kept on
saying was no peace no justice no peace
no justice they're in you're gonna have
labor unrest over the next year we're
gonna have a continuing divide between
corporate America and its people this is
significant the tension in the workforce
is going to be far greater there's a
lesson here that economic freedom is
under direct attack
yeah and Laura I don't mean to overstate
it but it is significant now I could not
agree more and finally them that
embattled NYC Mayor Bill DeBlasio Frank
he was ranting a lot last night but this
moment really stood out to you watch for
40 years the rich have gotten richer and
they paid less and less in taxes it
cannot go on this way when I'm president
we will even up the score and we will
tax the hell out of the wealthy to make
this a fairer country this has to be the
party that's not afraid to say out loud
we're going to tax the hell out of the
wealthy he said it twice just so you
would understand why was that moment's
and he said to be because he said the
beginning he said at the end and the
audience erupted an applause that was
his best moment among Democrats that was
his best moment of the debate Laura this
is not just about politics this is not
just about winning the Democratic
nomination this is about changing the
structure of the economy in the United
States and they are determined to turn
it upside down and I got to tell you
I've been following this since 1992 I've
never heard candidates this extreme I've
never heard candidates this hostile to
economic freedom and they've got the
base of the Democratic everybody
absolutely behind them yeah I say
freedom period sorry empty freedom on
what kind of car you drive or whether
you can fly somewhere as long as they're
able to fly to their stupid conferences
that's okay but the rest of the little
people they're just gonna have to go and
you know those little green scooters or
whatever all right Frank fantastic to
see you tonight